thank you
[Music]
okay try to picture this entire crime
because it's a crazy scenario and
there's a lot to think about
a husband
kidnaps his own wife because they're
going through some problems and he
decides to get all crazy so he kidnaps
her
tapes her eyes and mouth shut
and then he uh puts her in a vehicle
they drive to a location that she
doesn't know where they are takes her
out of the vehicle stabs her in the
chest wow buries her alive in a grave
that he does and then sticks a tree on
top of the grave
wow after all of this is said and done
she grows out of the tree she had to
grow out of the tree she'd busts out the
tree without it yeah the [ __ ] flower
she's alive she becomes a fruit and then
she pops out and says [ __ ] I'm
mango
mango man and she gets her revenge
you [ __ ] mangled me yeah you make oh
man plus three all right no she uh she
does end up Surviving the entire ordeal
how do you think she did it and if you
were in the situation how would you do
it how do you get it I would try to have
a hole while he buries me like this with
a bulbous I could breathe through the
roots
that's creative she survived wait she
made it so and the cops arrested the guy
good was the knife stuck in her or was
it she just got shanked with something
out so she was bleeding she ate the dirt
oh my God the dirt actually like shut up
your wounds stop the bleeding he
cauterized it that's some [ __ ] kill
Bill [ __ ] imagine that you're you you
got stabbed you're in the dirt there's a
tree on top of you
how could you possibly get help she dug
he got the tree from somewhere he
couldn't have gotten it from or like he
stole the tree and he the person came
back where's my drink where's my [ __ ]
tree and there it is and then she had
her cell phone close close really
even closer to the watch that's it there
it is what is it the Apple watch Apple
watch and then what happened did she say
call 9-1-1 what happened is at the time
here's the timeline so at the time that
he taped her eyes and mouth shut he went
out of the room to get more [ __ ] at that
moment she called 9-1-1 on Apple watch
unable to see or speak and she you just
hear the call and she's just going
wow yeah and off of that they were able
to when she was taken to that site where
they buried her and everything they were
able to like uh pretty much get a beat
on her location but still even though
she was in the ground she still managed
they still have a reception no she still
managed to get out of her bindings and
dig herself out of the [ __ ] grave so
she she wow he sucked that digging
Graves he doesn't know any [ __ ] knots
he didn't stab deep he doesn't know how
to [ __ ] Berry [ __ ] or plant a tree
like idiot he didn't make sure that she
was dead also can you talk on into your
Apple watch that sucks terrible yeah you
can't you can't can yeah even when
you're when your phone's not there what
the hell it's Ron skolsday who did this
that's who did it damn it's an Asian man
is this in Asia no this is the third
[ __ ] um where was this this is in uh
in Washington I'm surprised [ __ ]
Asian With Attitudes not reporting all
this stuff they I think they did okay
they do a lot of Asian dudes are bad at
killing their wives huh
yeah so uh she was and the crazy thing
is when she got herself out and moved
the tree out of the way he was still in
the in the van like she could see him
wow but then she snuck that she snuck
that out pretty fast she got back in
well he just didn't leave right away he
dropped the ball in everything yeah yeah
pretty much maybe he was watching and
just going haha
into how crazy it sounds
oh that's crazy
imagine having to call 911 why wouldn't
9-1-1 go hello
oh my God is there like an SOS you can
do when your mouth is like when you do
like Morse code or something you know
when you even called this this is
already an SOS yeah right there is that
but let's say it's like through sound
like let's say you're trying to
communicate but you can't say words oh
like is there a way to say like SOS yeah
you would go dispatcher needs to know
Morse code
that's SOS oh it is s-o-s
Bubba
SOS dispatcher's lineup she was kind of
tired
one more time
nice
that's great that's good to know though
that's good to know yeah it is good to
know do you think he did did her mouth
first because she was complaining a lot
I mean there's a lot to complain about
yeah the situation
I wonder what they argued about
um apparently they argued about a lot of
things because they were married for a
long time and were kind of in the middle
of a wonderful divorce we were wearing a
blue shirt I bet you they were arguing
over her fall recipe
one of the biggest things that they were
fighting what what uh what Asian is that
that's Vietnamese see I told you right I
mean it could be a couple other things
but Titan it looks like it looks like
Vietnamese wait let me see how do you
spell it
c-h-a-e and then a-n-a-e that's that
sounds Korean that's like Hmong dude oh
yeah oh yeah this is Young her name is
Young oh Young on yeah okay
but they also look Korean where is it
where is it at Washington
there's a lot of Koreans in Washington
but I also respect the um the dispatcher
to like actually put it through because
it was me it would be like ah this is
[ __ ] dude I feel like in L.A they
would just protocol for that to not be
just [ __ ] you don't think so muffled
cry to a 9-1-1 okay fine in L.A I feel
like that's why you're not dispatcher
it's okay that's right so people some
jobs aren't a good fit you know it's
like I'm sorry I can't understand you
is that um
what's the address again but it is
pretty cool that like they did file it
so when she made that call they did file
it under a female heard screaming
sounded gagged oh that's so they
correctly identified did yeah what if
it's a man they just skip it huh
dude don't be kind of [ __ ] up and
choking on Glizzy
yeah a big man it's like
stop being a [ __ ] yeah yeah get
yourself out of this yourself yeah dude
yeah I wonder what like
um the motive outside of just pure evil
it is you know what I mean it's like
there's yeah I would not think that like
Murder by itself uh for hate was the
thing that would prompt a married couple
to do that it's kind of like like life
insurance is always like a huge part
right like committing murder obviously
not trying to get caught collecting on
something so it was more valuable than
just ridding yourself the wrong way of
someone can I see this picture again
yeah but you better say something really
good because I gotta [ __ ] click this
thing oh sorry because it look was he
smiling he kind of was smiling in his
mug shot no he was I mean he was like
you know oh his eyes are smiling yeah
he's all like I did it well also these
could also be mug shots from a prior you
never know like could be from when he
[ __ ] stole a place I mean he could be
a JK news fan too so you better watch
out he's probably just crazy odds are
yeah he's really bad at killing people
though that's for sure all right do you
know what is interesting though is it
like for domestic abuse and domestic
murder those are things that tend to
happen a lot with guys that don't have
priors yeah this is very irrational
yeah and like because of crimes of
passion a lot of crimes of passion stem
from people that have never really done
anything like that rather than like a
[ __ ] some biker gang looking dude
that has had like five priors like
that's not but he had to have one moment
where he's like I know it'll make this
better I'm gonna put a tree on top
like that part was probably the best
part of the plan everything else was
like kind of sloppy but that's probably
when it's like a a Heat of the Moment
like he like freaked out and was like
all right well I can't turn back now
with this thing
nobody will know what if he just did
that tree though
yeah but also maybe he just did that as
a punishment and it's a tree like like a
down or is it like upright imagine he
planted it it was all like this and
somebody was like that tree looks kind
of weird I'm gonna bury her under a tree
that's a sus Oak
yeah to just cover the whole body so you
put it like that I hope it wasn't a
Christmas tree because that's pretty
stupid Christmas is coming right around
the corner it's the wrong season they're
just gonna someone's gonna take that
tree and notice that there was a body in
the bottom it's a Douglas Bird yeah
funny the funny thing is I I have seen
that detectives a lot of the time
especially homicide detectives they can
very easily tell when a crime is
committed in haste because if there's
certain signs that like they did it
rushed it's very easy to go okay
somebody [ __ ] didn't plan for this to
happen
when that's why they always look for
signs of a struggle in the area because
when you see signs of a struggle in the
area then it was less planned but if you
don't see anything out of place then
you're like oh maybe the body was moved
here or maybe oh maybe it happened I'm
thinking about the two detectives there
there though it's like was this done in
haste
there's a tree on top
that's not the case book yeah you know
yeah it's like kind of like bullshitted
together plants versus like something
professional he was a sloppy sloppy man
dude about a ficus
that's dirty murder if I ever saw
there's no crime and passion here I bet
there's like assassins out there that
are looking at articles like this like
man they're all judging it because
they're more like the hardcore ones
because real assassins like you don't
even know they were there yeah that's
the thing like I watched this I watched
this really cool special talking to this
like Assassin in Mexico and a lot of his
killings are very simple and they don't
even involve hiding a body he's like if
you go that far you're too personally
connected right oh so he's like if you
use murder him on the street yeah if you
just kill him and that's and that's the
only point of evidence like that's the
only crime site yeah then they're
limited yeah there's no dragging there's
no like checking other things it's just
like walk up yeah yeah it's too personal
those guys are the motorcycles and [ __ ]
they pull up
and he was saying too like if you're a
professional assassin then you're
already in the network where you're
provided the weapon like so if you want
to hire somebody you have to provide all
the [ __ ] because they can't be connected
to it so you're the one that's like okay
here's the gun this is and you have to
give him the timetable about where and
how yeah in a manila folder what if
you're the one providing a weapon and
then you're also cheap and you give them
like this shitty ass kitchen knife and
they're like come on I can't work with
this but imagine the other assassin it's
like you're providing the weapon you're
like hey here's a tree
challenge
let your imagination take you away you
know what's funny is like so this is in
Washington right so it's probably like
full of these like Christmas tree things
what if this dude got a [ __ ] banana
tree or some tropical tree that doesn't
even fit
that [ __ ] he's like that's not native
yeah yeah so I'm planted
I thought that's what you were saying
like you see a Christmas tree yeah
at the top